Buenas tardes a todos los que ya se
están conectando a nuestra charla de
hoy, que va a ser justamente sobre
Peach, sobre cómo podemos realmente
vender esta solución, porque muchas
veces cuando estamos en los hackatons
pensamos que simplemente decir ya aquí
tengo mi producto, ya tengo mi MVP y
simplemente miren cómo funciona, está
listo. con que eso funcione,
consideramos que de una vez los jurados
van a decir, "Uf, me encanta, voy con
toda, con este, tiene que ser el
ganador." Pero realmente no funciona
tanto así. Nosotros les dimos como o les
comentamos que tenemos eh 2 minutos
donde ustedes van a tener o van a poder
subir su pit de 2 minutos donde pues la
idea es que hablen un poco del proyecto
y de una muestren cómo funciona y
justamente para eso, para aprender cómo
hacer el mejor pit posible en esos
minutos. Hoy traemos a Ángela que la
conozco desde hace bastante tiempo y
tengo la fortuna de haber estado en
conjunto eh trabajando con ella en
hackatons, tanto desde el lado de
mentorías también como el lado de
participantes. Y sé que ha ganado varios
hackaton justamente gracias a esa
habilidad de vender muy bien esa idea
que se desarrolló. Así que hoy
justamente ella nos va a comentar un
poco pues cómo podemos hacer eso, cómo
podemos utilizar esos 2 minutos de la
mejor forma posible para crear el mejor
pitch posible. Y yo creo que esto es uno
de los talleres o una de las charlas que
realmente puede ser un poco
menospreciado porque todo el mundo
piensa, tengo que enfocarme en construir
en hacer el mejor producto, pero
realmente es una de las charlas más
importantes porque tienes 2 minutos para
convencer a los jurados de que tu
solución es la mejor y para que sigan
viendo exactamente cómo funciona,
etcétera. Así que por eso llamamos esta
charla gana el mejor pit, aprende cómo
hacerlo para que ustedes puedan salir de
aquí con todas las herramientas para
hacer el mejor pit posible. Así que
Ángela, te doy la bienvenida por acá. Me
encantaría que te presentaras, que nos
cuentes un poquito quién eres y de una
comenzamos la las charlas.
Ah, Sandra, qué bueno ah verte por acá.
Como como lo mencionas y hemos tenido la
oportunidad de participar en varios
hackatons y yo hoy quisiera como intro
solo decir, me encantaría compartirles
un poquito de todo lo que la vida nos ha
enseñado con estos ejercicios. Así que
nada, feliz de estar acá.
Me encanta. Bueno, el escenario es tuyo
para que nos puedas compartir cómo hacer
ese pH. Así que cualquier cosa, yo estoy
por detrás. Cualquier apoyo que
necesites, levanta la mano aquí ando y
te después de que finalices tu charla
vamos a ver los comentarios, vamos a ver
qué preguntas hay y apoyamos a resolver
todas esas dudas.
Buenísimo. Entonces, podemos comenzar.
Bien, dicho eso, quiero empezar diciendo
que comencé analizando el website que
tienen de Colicidio y 30X. genial
iniciativa, no solo para Colombia, sino
para el resto de la región en este
formato híbrido. Y hoy quisiera
compartirles ah algunos aprendizajes
para poder que se disfruten este hacaton
al máximo y además le puedan sacar todo
el provecho. Partiendo por decir que
construir es solo la mitad de participar
en un hackaton. La otra mitad es que eso
que construyeron se entienda en 2
minutos. Ah, y parece simple. ah puede
llegar a serlo. Ah, pero como Sandra
mencionó al principio, también puede
llegar a ser un poco olvidado. Entonces,
ah, también creo que algo que quisiera
comunicarles es que el hackaton no es
solo llegar, construir una idea y
explicarla. Yo creo que muchas veces
menospreciamos la importancia de estas
iniciativas y para mí tiene tres cosas
fundamentales. Uno, que pueden aprender
un montón, desde nuevos koss técnicos
hasta nuevas habilidades sociales. Eh, y
además con todo esto, la inteligencia
artificial nos ayuda a acelerar un
montón este espacio de construcción para
que aceleremos el aprendizaje, pero
también hagamos muchas conexiones y
utilicemos esto en pro del desarrollo de
nuestras carreras profesionales. ¿Por
qué? Porque también tenemos la capacidad
de hacer networking, hablar con
personas, con mentores, hacer nuevos
amigos y, ¿por qué no?, construir su red
profesional. Yo creo que esta es una de
las formas en las que yo más he hecho
conexiones en el tiempo, sobre todo
amigos en el tiempo. Ah, así que eso,
creo que a veces se nos olvida que estos
eh actividades son un gran espacio
también para desarrollar a nuestras
redes de ah contacto. Para además ah
conectarlo con el portafolio. Creo que
una de las cosas que he cambiado con
tanta inteligencia artificial es que es
mucho más difícil allá afuera solo
aplicar a a una a un trabajo y que nos
llamen directamente. Por eso hoy en día
es mucho más clave poder mostrar qué si
hacer con lo que tengo. Y los proyectos
de Jaatons, además de que podrían darnos
posibles premios, también nos permiten
generar o crear este portafolio que
muestre nuestro valor profesional y
cuáles son las habilidades que puedo
llevar a a ejecución y cuáles son los
proyectos que puedo llevar a ejecución
con esta suma de cosas que tengo. En
resumen, para mí un hack es un
simulario, un simulacro, un simulacro de
el trabajo real que puedo llevar
haciendo con mis amigos o compañeros o
mi equipo, en el que hay que empezar a
hablar, desarrollar ideas, qué haces tú,
qué hago yo, en el que me comunico no
solo con mi equipo, sino con personas
allá afuera, stakeholders o como quieran
llamarlo, además de que tengo que vender
esta idea o iniciativa que tengo y por
supuesto ah termino ganando mucha
habilidad. Dicho eso, ustedes se
preguntarán, "Bueno, pero ¿de dónde has
aprendido esto, Ángela?" Ahora sí me
puedo sentar. Eh, yo tuve la oportunidad
de ah dirigir uno de los proyectos de
educación más lindos ah y más grandes de
la región en Plati y la escuela de
blockchain. Y luego de eso, en un
momento en mi en mi carrera en el que no
sabía qué dirección a seguir, decidí
participar en hackatons. Gané algunos de
ellos online y también en persona. Ah, y
lo más curioso es que en el camino esos
hackatons me llevaron a conectar con
mentores que luego me dieron la
oportunidad de organizar estos
hackatons. Básicamente algo así como,
mira, tú ya has participado en varios de
esos, ¿no te gustaría ayudarme a
organizar uno? Y terminé por un tiempo
en mi vida organizando a estas
competencias a nivel global y en persona
con algunos de ellos más de $100,000 eh
en premios. Y finalmente, yo diría que
hoy en mi trabajo actual es una de las
tareas que más realizo viajando por el
mundo, ya no solo desde la tarea de
organizadora, sino es de jurado.
Entonces, digamos que puedo tener un
cúmulo de experiencias desde alguien que
ha participado, alguien que los ha
organizado y quien está del otro lado eh
juzgando a estos proyectos. Así que
finalmente esperemos que hoy podamos
aprender a entender cómo ganar estas
presentando el mejor pitch. Para ello
quiero dividir esta charla rápidamente
en tres temas. Uno, cómo aprovechar las
acato. Esto es más que una oportunidad
para pichar. Es algo que va mucho más
allá y que podría ser antes y un después
en sus carreras oíidas. Ah, lo segundo
es cómo hacer el pat ganador. Simple, un
prompt sencillito o un cúmulo de
instrucciones sencillas. Ah, y luego
recomendaciones post hackaton de cómo
pueden sacarle provecho a eso. Lo
primero es, enfoquémonos en el ahora.
Ustedes empezaron a hackear ayer, ah,
deberían estar entregando el domingo.
Todavía quedan un poco de días. Si están
en con subsidio en este momento o están
online, todos pueden aprovechar esta
oportunidad. Y yo comenzaría con lo que
la mayoría ignora, hablen con los
mentores desde el día uno o en ese caso
el día dos porque ustedes ya comenzaron.
Ah, y eso significa vayan y pidan ayuda
o hagan las preguntas a las personas que
ya han pasado por algunos de estos retos
profesionales, sea a través de un canal,
no sé si están usando WhatsApp o qué
canal de comunicación, ah, o en persona.
La razón es que la inteligencia
artificial o los agentes los van a tener
ahí todos los días, pero estas personas
no las van a poder potencialmente tener
tan cerca todo el tiempo. Esta es la
oportunidad. Es que soy tímida. Sí, te
toca hacerlo. ¿Por qué? Porque también
es una gran forma de aprender de otro
tipo de conocimientos, de tener una
nueva forma de argumentar o básicamente
de potencialmente conectar con personas
que en el futuro te puedan eh conectar a
otras cosas. Ah, lo segundo es conecta
con otros equipos, participantes,
mentores. En serio, aunque por eso la la
parte más incómoda de una hackatun a la
que más se le puede sacar provecho. No
en el sentido de hola, te conozco y esto
es lo que necesito de ti, sino con
curiosidad genuina de ir a preguntar, la
verdad es que este es mi primer
hackaton. Me gustaría saber si tienes
algunos consejos. Hola, estos son los
tracks de esta jacaton de col subsidio
30x. Esta es mi idea, pero no sé qué
opinas. podrías darme algún consejo o
básicamente, hola, la verdad es que
estoy construyendo esta interfaz, pero
no sé dónde poner este o este botón o
mira, esto es lo que propone mi agente,
¿será que me puedes ayudar a hacer A, B
o Z? Esto lo puedes preguntar a todos,
equipos, participantes, mentores, de
nuevo, empiecen por lo que la mayoría
ignora y es ahora tenemos la oportunidad
de crear más rápido. Conecte, es
diferencial y es el diferencial o la
clave más importante en estos días.
Luego alinean al equipo antes de
escribir código. Eh, yo creo que esto
fue algo ah que tenía escrito hace
mucho. Yo participaba en Hackatons antes
de que ahí fuese tan ah popular o
estuviese tan enrutado en nuestras
vidas. Ah, y en el que escribir
[carraspeo] código era manito. Ah, así
que esto se me queda muy en la mente,
pero igual lo quería compartir. Yo creo
que hoy lo que hace diferente eh
trabajar en un equipo a antes es que de
pronto la parte técnica está ahí, pero
es muy importante estar comunicados para
poder saber hacia qué dirección llevar
un proyecto. Y esto va a pasar en una
hackaton, pero también va a pasar en
cualquier otro trabajo. Así que alguien
en el equipo va a tener que tomar la
decisión de sentarse y entender cuáles
son las expectativas de cada uno. En el
pasado, como ejemplo, participábamos con
varios amigos y algunos en el camino no
nos comprometíamos tanto, me incluyo en
el paquete, o en otros, por ejemplo, nos
bloqueábamos y no sabíamos cómo
comunicar ese bloqueo. Lo importante
entonces es que definan roles, que
entiendan cuáles son sus escenarios
esperados y por supuesto que desde el
principio elijan quién va a presentar.
Busquen a la persona que se sienta capaz
de hacer la presentación y en el camino
todos le van a ayudar a prepararse. Ojo,
todos se ponen nerviosos y nerviosas en
el momento de hacer una de estas
presentaciones, créanme, todos. Ah,
entonces eso muy claro, definen roles
quién presenta desde el inicio y además
creen estos escenarios. Mi consejo es
que creen tres, muy simple. Keep
example, escenario uno es lo mínimo que
funcione. Yo voy a crear una empresa de
crédito. ¿Qué significa eso? Voy a tener
un botón en el que voy a poder prestar a
4% anual. Claro, eso ya es algo mucho
más simple, es un botón. Escenario dos,
si nos sobra tiempo, entonces también
voy a agregar una landing que explique
de qué es el producto. Perfecto. Y si
nos sobra tiempo, entonces voy a crear
esta aplicación completa que tiene A B y
C feature o AB C Ah. cosas ah que
podrían usar mis usuarios. Definan eso
desde el inicio porque a pesar de que el
tiempo corre y ustedes dirán, "El
domingo todavía está muy lejos", se va a
pasar. Y al final es donde las emociones
afloran y donde el equipo tiene que
mantenerse alineado. De nuevo, esto es
un simulacro de un trabajo real, así que
úsenlo como tal. Cuiden la energía,
turnos, descanso, comida, tanto si están
en persona como si están en online, en
muchas oportunidades. Nos teníamos que
quedar hasta tarde durmiendo y cuando
hay poco sueño y no hay
buen cuidado de la energía, de nuevo,
las emociones salen a flote y eso puede
pasar no solo en una hackaton, sino en
un trabajo. Usen esto como una
oportunidad para incrementar eh cada uno
de esos skills. Ah, y créanme, cerca del
pitch es cuando la cosa se pone
emocionante. Entonces eso, conecten con
la gente, diviértanse, pero también
alineen sus expectativas desde el
inicio. Yo soy Pepito Pérez, mi plan es
ganar o morir o ganar y ganar.
O mi plan es la verdad me quiero
divertir o yo solo quiero aprender a
usar esta nueva herramienta en este
jackaton. Entonces, cuando ya eso está
claro, tú sabes a qué nivel de
compromiso puedes esperar y qué puedes
esperar de tus compañeros al mismo
tiempo. Construye pensando en el final,
algo pequeño le que funcione le gana a
una idea enorme a medias. Es decir,
enfóquense en que las cosas al final se
vean bien y que se puedan usar, porque a
veces nos emocionamos con que voy a
construir Facebook en un día, pero luego
termina un poco roto, cuando la ambición
se va a quiero hacer todo a la vez y no
me enfoco de poco a mucho, eh, y voy al
paso contrario. Documenten también
mientras avanzan. Esto lo digo porque
funciona mucho para quien presenta tener
como todo el cúmulo de ideas de qué ha
ido pasando en el camino para al final
entender cómo
mostrar esto. Otra cosa que funciona,
esto puede ser un poco más
de lado técnico quizás, pero mantener
commits limpios, qué hice en esto qué
hice en lo otro hoy no es superfácil
preguntarle a la gente y que vaya
subiendo los cambios respectivamente.
Si no han usado esto, pregúntenle a su
gente que los guíe para integrar todo
esto en GitHub o en Git y de esa forma
pueden tener como trazabilidad de hacia
dónde están yendo esos cambios. Ah,
cuando alguien audita, además, es decir,
cuando los jurados a nivel técnico vayan
a revisar su código, si ocurre, es mucho
más fácil tener comits limpios que solo
un comid y todo el repo
y luego prioriza el camino a que vas a
mostrar en la demo. Cuando vayan a hacer
la presentación, ya vamos a ir a ello,
es muy importante que puedan mostrar
cómo su aplicación hace aquellos que
ustedes están tratando de explicar.
Entonces, para mí es super importante
que creen, se enfoquen en el demo. Es
como que yo estoy construyendo una casa
ah, y tengo una sala y tengo una cocina
y tengo unas oficinas, pero mi misión es
mostrar la sala porque en la sala es
donde está lo más lindo de mi casa.
Listo, enfóquense en que eso quede muy
bien para que luego puedan grabar eh ese
recorrido de la de la aplicación,
pero con criterio. ¿Y por qué digo esto?
Ah, jugando un montón de aplicaciones
durante el último año o dos, me doy
cuenta que, de nuevo, a veces esa esa
esas ganas de hacer todo rápido hace que
que la alucine un poquito y que termine
con landing pages que tienen 1000
botones y que las personas no saben
explicar qué o por qué. Entonces, mi
recomendación muy concreta es usen el
plan mode, es decir, vayan a una gente y
hablen con vos si pueden. Ah, y díganle,
"Esto es lo que quiero hacer. Hazme
todas las preguntas que necesites para
tener todo el contexto a mi lado y así
que me puedas dar un un un plan que
podamos revisar juntos antes de que
ocurra o antes de que ejecutes. Mi otra
mi otra consejo es pídele que te dé dos
o tres versiones de ese proyecto que
tanto visualizas en tu cabeza.
Finalmente, compara a los agentes. Por
ejemplo, yo suelo usar diferentes
modelos y uno le pregunta al otro o el
uno lo argumenta con otro. pueden usar,
no sé, Cloud o Cursor o Cognition o
Gemini, lo que sea, pero creo que esto
es muy importante. Es decir, no tienen
que hacer tramajo manual, eso quedó en
el pasado, pero sí tienen que usar las
herramientas que hoy existen con
criterio para poder generar el mejor
resultado posible. y cuiden la interfaz.
Es muy ah, no sé si les pasa, pero a mí
me pasa que hoy es muy obvio entender
cuando un texto fue escrito con así como
una interfaz o algún proyecto o algún
producto fue hecho con AI. Hay ciertas
cosas que a nivel diseño ya tú dices,
"Okay, esto lo hizo una gente y alguien
ah decidió dejar eh ese tipo de cosas."
Ahorita les voy a dar un par de
herramientas que seguramente les van a
hacer la vida mucho más fácil, pero yo
diría eso. La está ahí para apalancar,
pero úsenla con mucho criterio. Usen el
planote, hablen con vos si pueden, es
buenísimo. Revisen el plan y luego sí
ejecutan. Es la diferencia total entre
que alguien vea su producto y diga, "Ah,
wow, esto me gusta." Ah, oh, wow, esto
alguien más se lo pidió a una y no saben
lo que hicieron. Ojalá se entienda, eh,
pero creo que es bastante importante. Y
luego algunas herramientas que les
podrían servir. Ah, yo en particular
creo que estas son cosas un poco
básicas, pero que capaz eh cuando entren
van a decir, "Wow, wow, wow, eh no sé
cómo usar esto." Denle 5 minutos a cada
una y luego pueden continuar. La primera
es vecero de Versel. Ah, este les
permite prototipar las interfaces muy
fácil, eh, solo pidiéndole con lenguaje
natural, es decir, "Hola, eh, veero, yo
quiero hacer una aplicación para
gestionar seguros en Colombia, eh, que
creo que era uno de los tracks." O
también puede buscar templates, es
decir, otras personas que ya han hecho
plataformas en el pasado y que te dejan
como una ah sí, como un template
parecido a lo que a ti te gustaría
lograr. De esa forma ya tienes eh algo
por lo cual empezar. Eh, luego tienes
Versel Mentlefy. Cuando los jueces vayan
a ver su producto, ustedes necesitan un
demo, es decir, un lugar en el que los
jueces vayan y prueben que lo que
ustedes dijeron que hicieron funcione.
Versel o Metle F les van a ayudar con el
deployment. Ya les hablé de los agentes
ah y de GitHub para que puedan subir
esos cambios. Hoy la lo ha hecho mucho,
mucho, mucho más fácil. No se abrumen, 5
minutos y van a poder continuar. Eh,
honestamente no deberían hacer nada
malo. Cloud, cursor, cognition, Codex,
Gemini, pensar, codear, destrabarse, lo
que quieran. Todas estas herramientas
están evolucionando en paso increíble.
Yo las uso en mi día a día, así que
definitivamente vayan eh con ello. Si
necesitan bases de datos, Neon o Supase.
Ah, lo escribí mal, pero Supase. Es la
base de datos. Neon es increíble
también, de hecho es mucho más ah
barata. el tier free les debería
alcanzar para hacer todo el proyecto de
estas acaton. Entonces también échenlo
el ojo. Este es más para trabajo en
equipo. Entonces, por ejemplo, a mí me
sirve diagramar lo que está en mi cabeza
y poder compartirlo. Excalidro eh es una
pizarra online en la que puedes colocar
todos tus pensamientos. Eh, y también
capaz si hay algo que no saben cómo
explicárselo a la gente o a sus
compañeros, lo ponen ahí y luego debería
ser eh mucho más ah fácil continuar con
el proyecto. Y finalmente, skills. Si
van a a internet skills.shsh,
esta es una herramienta que lanzó Versel
y que básicamente tiene un montón de
instrucciones muy concretas para que
puedan acelerar sus proyectos. Hay unas
en particular que tienen que ver con las
interfaces que ya mencioné. Entonces,
pueden buscar las de Antropic para
diseño o las de Versel para diseño.
Busquen toda la lista de skills que hay
y pues de acuerdo al proyecto que
necesiten también podrían potencialmente
usarlas, que es un skill, una serie de
instrucciones que tu agente tiene para
que no tengas que repetir el contexto,
sino que ya esté como en el core del
proyecto en particular. Entonces repito,
Bero Vero, Blify, cualquiera de sus
agents, base de datos Neon y Supabase
Excalidroid Skills. Yo creo que además
de que se usan en una hackaton, es algo
que se usa en un entorno de trabajo en
el día a día. Entonces, si le dan la
oportunidad de 5 minutos a cada una, se
llevan un montón ah de de un nuevo stack
para que puedan eh trabajar. Si no son
personas técnicas, les prometo que si le
dan 5 minutos a cada una, al menos
tendrán un poco más de perspectiva de
panorama de cómo funciona este mundo. Y
de verdad, la vida se los va a hacer eh
mucho más fácil. Denle, denle una
oportunidad. Esto es hoy un parte del
stack ah de desarrollo allí afuera.
Luego, ahora sí vamos a al pitch. Tienen
2 minutos, 2 minutos y ya han
aprovechado jueves, viernes, sábado, han
hablado con su equipo, les han dicho,
"Muchachos, el viernes yo voy a dormir o
todas las noches yo voy a dormir no
negociable. Esto va a ser lo que pueden
esperar de mí. Ah, yo voy a preparar el
pitch o no. ¿Yo voy a hacer el backend o
no? Yo voy a hacer ah los lights. Ya
están todos organizados. Es momento de
preparar el pitch. Lo primero es,
empiecen con tiempo. No dejen esto para
el domingo una hora antes. Quien sea que
se vaya a dedicar a hacer el pitch,
dedíquenle, por favor tiempo. Y tienen
dos. Así que mi propuesta es, empiecen
con un hook o algo que llame la atención
y explicando el problema. 20 segundos.
¿Qué construiste? 20 segundos. Demo en
vivo, 50 segundos. El texta o o cuál fue
la infraestructura o qué herramientas
usaron y por qué importa. 10. El equipo
que sigue el cierre 20 segundos.
Instrucción clara. Tómle una foto a
esto. Ah, y ya se los voy a explicar a
detalles. ¿Qué hacen los primeros 20
segundos? Explican, ah, o empiezan con
una pregunta fuerte. La mayoría de las
personas comienzan diciendo, "Hola, me
llamo Ángela y soy de Venezuela y vivo
en Colombia y entonces yo participo en
esta hackaton. 20 minutos gun, 20
segundos gun, se fueron." Y los jueces,
honestamente, no van a prestar la misma
atención a que si empiezan dejando un
problema claro con una sola frase o con
un solo texto. Ah, y también es muy
importante si tienen eh utilizar datos o
analogías que conecten a esa idea.
Entonces, por ejemplo, fui a los tracks
y vi que hay una de ah viviendas. En
Colombia en 2025 cerca de 4.8 millones
de hogares se quedaron en déficit de
vivienda. ¿Cuántos de ellos califican
para un subsidio y nunca lo reclaman? No
por falta de plata solamente, sino por
falta de información. Ahí la cosa
cambia. En 20 segundos estoy diciendo,
¿de qué está hablando esta muchacha? Y
qué me trata de presentar versus
simplemente comenzar con una eh
introducción
normal, pero que en este caso no es tan
necesaria porque tenemos que ir a prisa.
¿Qué construiste en 20 segundos?
Describe el producto en una frase. ¿Qué
lo hace distinto? el caso de uso central
y no la lista de features. ¿Qué creaste
a partir de ese problema que
presentaste? Ah, construimos mi
subsidio. En tres preguntas te dice a
qué subsidio calificas y te arma una
solicitud. 20 segundos. Continuamos.
Demo en vivo. En este momento, mi
recomendación es que en el ejemplo de la
sala vayan y graben solo ese paso en
particular en el que se quieren enfocar.
Que la website es muy linda y que tienes
un montón de features y un montón de
colores. Perfecto. Acá te vas a enfocar
en el problema que estás eh tratando
resolver. Entonces, enseña el flujo
real, responde las tres preguntas, match
de subsidios, solicitud generada, pum,
sigo. Ah, otra recomendación sería que
si no sé cómo funcionan las submissions,
eh, Sandra nos dirá en un momento, pero
si es submitir a un form, entonces
graben el backup. E si si tienen que
presentarlo en vivo, graben el backup
por si fai y el wifi. Si no, grábense la
pantalla y después le ponen boss and off
o voz por encima cuando estén grabando
esto. Entonces,
Sandra, ¿tú sabes acá cómo funciona?
Claro. Sí. Eh, justamente lo que vamos a
hacer es que ellos van a tener una
plataforma donde van a creer, van a
crear sus equipos y adicional a eso, el
domingo van a poder subir pues su
proyecto. Igual el proyecto lo van a
poder crear por allí. Y yo sé que
ahorita todo el mundo me va a reventar
el WhatsApp diciendo, "¿Dónde está la
plataforma?",
Pero ya se la vamos a compartir durante
el día de hoy, no se preocupen, sigan
enfocados en el trabajo de de su
proyecto, pero sí, allí van a poder
poner toda la información y en este caso
el pitch es pregrabado y después estamos
haciendo lo mismo, un algo parecido a
Global donde tomamos los finalistas y
esos son los últimos que se van a
presentar frente al jurado final,
mejor dicho, la tenemos más clara que
nunca. Lo primero que van a hacer es
para la presentación de esta plataforma
que Sandra les va a enviar. graben la
pantalla y luego sobre esa pantalla le
ponen la voz o mientras van grabando van
poniendo la voz y eso lo ponen eh es un
en su presentación final. Ah, hay muchas
aplicaciones CapCut, ah la el mismo
Instagram o el celular les ayuda. Eh,
ustedes resolverán, pero esa es como mi
recomendación principal. Ahora, si
tienen que hacer una presentación en
vivo, practiquen muy bien ese paso a
paso para que si son finalistas se
puedan defender mejor con los jueces. Y
luego en 10 segundos o un poquito más
menos el ah stack tecnológico o el cumo
de las herramientas que usaron o por qué
usaron esas herramientas y por qué
importa. De nuevo, importante, van al
punto, ¿qué usaron? ¿Por qué importa
esta solución? ¿Y por qué col subsidio y
30x deberían seguir desarrollando estos
proyectos después de las acatonas? ¿Por
qué? ¿Por qué están en las hacat de col
subsidio y 30X? Y esto es muy distinto
al page que se hace a ONBC en donde hay
otras variables en juego. Acá lo
importante es qué usé y por qué es
importante. Entonces yo honestamente uso
un agente para desarrollar este ejemplo.
No sé si los números son 100% accurate,
pero quería proveerles de algo mucho más
concreto que solo un montón de bullets.
Entonces, basado en esto, en Colombia en
2025 cerca de 4.8 millones de hogares se
registraron en déficit de vivienda.
¿Cuántos de ellos califican por un
subsidio y nunca lo reclaman? No solo
por falta de dinero, sino también por
falta de información. Construimos mi
subsidio para responder a esta problema.
En tres preguntas te dice, ¿a qué
subsidio calificas y te arma la
solicitud? Les muestro el demo. 50
segundos después. Usamos la IA para leer
los requisitos de cada subsidio y
traducirlos a lenguaje simple y una base
de datos que cruza tu perfil con lo que
aplica para ti. El subsidio acompaña a
2.8 millones de afiliados y entregó 730
773,000 millones para viviendas en 2025.
Si con esto lográramos solo el 5% de
quienes no reclaman por desinformación y
ellos lo hicieran, hablamos de más de
100,000 familias con una vivienda más
cerca solo en Colombia. Y luego,
finalmente cierran equipo más que sigue
más cierra 20 segundos. Somos Pepito y
María. Uno construye, la otra vende y
los dos crecimos viendo nuestras
familias pelear con estos trámites. El
siguiente paso es un piloto de 3 meses
con subsidio si somos finalistas. Si
funciona con sus afiliados, funciona
para millones de colombianos que hoy no
saben que califican. Esto es lo que
queremos construir. Cierran. Es muy
distinto a un pitch tradicional, pero en
poco tiempo tienen la capacidad de
mostrarle a la gente, hey, hay un
problema real acá. Hey, mis papás lo
vivieron. Hey, esto es lo que estoy
proponiendo hoy. Hey, estoy listo para
trabajar con ustedes directamente y
hacer que esto ocurra en el futuro. Y si
no, aprendieron cómo hacer un pitch y
una aplicación en un fin de semana.
Muchachos, fuera de esto, como presentas
es tan importante como lo que acaban de
construir. Entonces, mi recomendación
muy honesta, basada en experiencia es
ensayen, repiten esto hasta que suene
natural con cronómetro hermano si hace
falta. Y la realidad es que todos nos
ponemos nerviosos, así que traten de
hablar con tanta energía y contacto
visual como puedan. Lo prometo. Esto
pone nerviosos a todo el mundo y a quien
no lo nota es porque lo he entrenado
bastante. Cuent una historia. Las
analogías o experiencias personales
conectan mucho con el jurado, realmente
con cualquier persona.
Y también traten de ser muy visuales. Si
se dan cuenta, yo he tratado acá de usar
muchos bullet points versus un párrafo
completo, porque a la vista es mucho más
fácil ir punto a punto que encontrarme
con una pared. Cuando me encuentro una
pared de texto es muy difícil que yo le
vaya a dar un ojo. Si tienen tiempo, yo
no lo tuve porque ajá, preparé esto
último minuto. Coloquen imágenes tantas
como puedan y esto mejora mucho más
que simplemente colocar texto. Y de
nuevo, cierren fuerte un call to action
que enganche. Por ejemplo, en este caso
estamos listos para trabajar con ustedes
y estamos listos ah para a no sé ayudar
a más de 100,000 familias
hipotéticamente en Colombia con este ah
producto de subsidios de vivienda.
Anticipa preguntas. Además, si ustedes
pasan a esta serie de finalistas que
Sandra mencionó, ah, seguramente les van
a hacer preguntas. Entonces, algo así
como, "¿Y qué harías si te da si en
estos tr meses te damos la oportunidad
de crear esto?" Ah, eh, no sé. Ah, o
¿qué harías si mañana te poníamos un
equipo de backen para construirlo? ¿Cuál
sería el stack que que elegirías? Hay
muchísimas preguntas. O, ¿cuál es el
potencial o tamaño de mercado para este
proyecto llevarse a cabo? o busque hasta
personas o competidores que ya haya
llevado esta idea. Imagínense todo tipo
de preguntas. Si no se las preguntan de
nuevo, aprendieron algo nuevo y lo más
importante es que pueden argumentar
porque hacen lo que hacen. Esto va mucho
más allá las hacaton y creo que fue mi
primer mensaje, pero quisiera recalcarlo
durante toda esta charla. Y luego,
simple gana, el pitch es solo el primer
paso, es decir, muchas veces nos
complicamos un montón. Entonces, esta es
una infraestructura
especializada en variables que no es una
aplicación que busca resolver este
problema. Piensen en quiénes están allí
afuera, no en como a mí me gustaría que
me lo expliquen, sino allá afuera, quién
está y lo más fácil manera para que me
puedan entender. Si no se entienden los
primeros 20 segundos, estás en
problemas. Si en los primeros 20
segundos hablaste de ti, estás en
problemas. La mayoría de los jugerados
revisan el repo o el código después, no
al principio. Lo que hacen los jueces al
principio es escuchar todas las charlas
y luego de eso hacen un resumen. Mmm, el
de Sandra me gustó. Vamos a guardarlo y
después revisamos su código. Así que tu
pitch abre la puerta y el código solo
confirma que lo que hiciste tiene
sentido y que lo que dijiste es cierto.
Así que mi recomendación a nivel de
código es en el Redmi o básicamente en
el file de introducción, en el
repositorio con links traten de que sea
lo más limpio y ordenado posible. Hay
veces que si son técnicos, el backend va
en un repo, el front end va en otro
repo. Pongan eso junto o en el Redmi
expliquen dónde están esos repositorios.
Y luego esto es una pequeña estructura
nada más. Ah, comiencen con sobre el
proyecto, fue construido con cómo
comenzar, si necesita la gente
instalarlo para poder probarlo o no.
Simplemente pónganles el link del demo,
el link al video, el Rap. ¿Qué pasaría
en esos tr meses hipotéticos en el que
ganaron las AATON de col subsidio con
30x y están listos para trabajar con
ellos? La licencia la escribí mal, pero
bueno. Ah, que básicamente es es open
source, es cerrada o no. Eh, pueden
preguntarle a esa gente. Contacto, es
decir, estoy lista ah, para llevar este
a cabo, ¿dónde me van a encontrar? Y en
acknowledgement, que es básicamente a
quienes ah quieren agradecer en
particular eh por ese trabajo. Yo solía
colocar los mentores o las personas que
en el camino eh me ayudaron o los
proyectos que me ayudaron. Esta puede
ser un detalle tontito, pero a mí me
servía además para ir luego a mis
repositorios y decir, "Ah, you know
what, yo construí con ese proyecto hace
3 años y fue muy divertido o la verdad
fue muy frustrante, sea cual sea la
experiencia, es parte del camino." Y
ahora sí, ya saben hacer un pitch, 2
minutos y tardó mucho más explicarlo,
pero espero que ah este pequeño prompt
les pueda ayudar. Hook, más problema.
¿Qué construyeron? Demo en vivo. Eh,
¿con qué lo construyeron? ¿Y por qué
importa? El equipo que sigue y cierre 2
minutos, 20 segundos, 20 segundos, 50,
10 y 20. Finalmente vamos con qué hacer
después del hackaton, porque la realidad
es que después del domingo la vida
continúa, algunos seguirán con su
proyecto, otros no, pero es una nueva
oportunidad para aprender. A mí
genuinamente me gusta como dejar una
especie de track record o ah o reporte o
recordatorio de las cosas que he ido
haciendo. Así que hagan un posto en
esto, qué construyeron, qué aprendieron,
que no salió, qué les hubiese gustado.
Lacesa perspectiva sirve además para
dejar visibilidad o trazabilidad de eso
que profesionalmente van haciendo y van
evolucionando. Tomen esto como un
simulacro de un trabajo. Muestren el
proceso. Si ganaron, muestren el proceso
más allá de los premios. La gente
conecta muchísimo con esto, sobre todo
en una época en la que uno sabe que
muchos posts han sido creados con
Entonces cuando hace falta esta conexión
genuina y humana, ese tipo de post tener
genuinamente emocionan un montón. Yo
después de los accatons voy y veo como
la gente que publicó ah sobre el pues el
protocolo que participó y nada, me
parece muy lindo, me parece muy lindo
ver como para algunas personas esta es
una oportunidad más de crecer
profesionalmente y para otras diversión,
para otras es conectar con amigos, para
otras fue un poco frustrante. Es es muy
lindo y genuino ver todas esas emociones
allá afuera. un post en esto de lo que
es sea que esto haya significado y pues
participen y y etiqueten a su equipo, a
los mentores, a los sponsors. ¿Por qué?
Porque además esto genera ah network
efectos de red en el que básicamente si
Sandra le dio like, pues los amigos de
Sandra lo van a ver. Si Carla le dio
like, todos van a estar ahí encima. Y
esto potencialmente te abra a más
personas allá afuera, sobre todo si
profesionalmente estás usando esto como
un apalancamiento. Y si quieres seguir,
usa laaton como validación. Digamos que
unos acá están creando este proyecto
para col subsidio, pero realmente
quieren lanzarlo como eh una empresa.
¿Tienen intención real de continuar?
Pues díganlo en público. Construimos
esto en Call Subsidio 30X. Esperamos que
sea solo un inicio. Déjenos saber si
están interesados. Nos encantaría tener
feedback. Si hay inversores allí afuera,
búsquenos. Queremos participar en la
red, queremos participar en una
aceleradora. conviertan a las personas a
las que tuvieron acceso durante esos
días en los primeros ah visitadores de
su proyecto y sobre todo las personas
que potencialmente podrían apoyarles.
TLDR o resumen de todo esto que dije,
ah, para mí un un hackaton, además de
una competición divertida en la que se
pueden ganar premios, es muchas veces el
principio de cosas más grandes.
Y si no es esteato, pues siguen
intentando. Pero para aquellos que
quieren ser desarrolladores,
quizás es una experiencia para poner en
práctica un nuevo stack o aprender a
usar una nueva base de datos o aprender
a usar un nuevo framework. Ya lo eres y
buscas trabajo, quizás esta es una
oportunidad para visualizarte mejor allá
afuera y que más personas te vean y que
puedas conectar con posiblemente
personas que en el futuro te vayan a dar
trabajo. Me pasó, terminé de organizar
ah de participar en hackatons, a
organizar una solo porque alguien vio
que era demasiado apasionada y que
potencialmente podría funcionar para
organizar una de estas cosas. No sabes
qué quieres. Ah, ve, intenta. Mira, la
verdad es que yo no sé si quiero hacer
código esta vez o no quiero y solo
quiero hacer slides. La verdad es que no
sé si esto me interesa. Prueben y
descobran. Ah, en una época profesional
en la que honestamente no tenía idea de
cuál era mi camino, las hacaton se me
ayudaron a entender un montón de cosas
profesionalmente de mí que no sabía y a
guiar mucho mejor eso. Eres un perfil no
técnico, que también es otra cosa que a
veces abruma, porque nos dicen, tienes
que saber este tipo de lenguaje de
programación.
No es necesario. La hoy está acelerando
un montón de procesos y además esto te
está dando la oportunidad de conectar
con mucha más gente allí afuera. Dale
una oportunidad a esto como un ¿Qué rol
quisiera desarrollar? El de ventas, el
de presentador, el de diseño, el de
producto, el de ingeniería o más el de
operaciones o quizá una mezcla de todos.
Alinear al equipo es parte de una tarea
diaria de alguien que trabaja en una
empresa. Así que acá hay espacio para
todos y todas y hay espacio para
aprender herramientas, stack técnico,
pero también muchas habilidades
sociales. Y yo creo que lo más
importante es de un patch y de una
hackaton es ah tratar de explicar qué
hace único tu proyecto, pero sobre todo
qué te hace único a ti como persona. Ah,
así que es una es una gran oportunidad
para aprender un montón. Yo de nuevo
pasé de no saber qué quería después de
una etapa de trabajar en educación a
encontrar un montón de oportunidades y
amigos. Sandra incluid en el paquete en
la que muchas madrugadas estuvimos
aplicando a hackatons y demás y luego
finalmente entender que quería y se hizo
tan claro que una de las personas que
conocí en estas hackatons terminó
introduciéndome como organizadora a otro
y ese es finalmente el trabajo que hoy
hago. Así que todos estos puntos que en
el presente usualmente no vemos, en el
futuro tienen un montón de sentido.
Aprovéchenlo y creo que lo más
importante es diviértanse. Hoy veo al
pasado y honestamente me hace muy feliz
saber que hubo un montón de noches en
las que no dormíamos. Seguramente
ustedes acá tendrán más chance. En esa
época no estaba Claud
Pero definitivamente ah fue muy
divertido. Conocimos a diferentes
personas. Ah, hubo muchos viajes detrás
de eso. Ah, hubo un montón de
aprendizajes detrás de eso, pero sobre
todo hubo un montón de diversión ah
detrás de todo ello. Así que espero que
en esta jaca todos y todas se diviertan
mucho, que ganen los premios ah y en el
mejor de los casos, que siempre hay uno
mejor versus peores. Aprendan, aprendan,
diviértanse y que esto sea una
oportunidad para conectar con la
industria y con ustedes mismos. So,
muchas gracias. Ah, cualquier pregunta
feliz, pero les voy a dejar esto acá por
si acaso y si no mejor este para que no
se les olvide. Sandra, lo logré. Todo
tuyo.
Buenísimo. Gracias, Ángela. Me encantó.
Me vas a tener que pasar esta
presentación porque seguramente todo el
mundo me lo va a pedir y así de una ya
van a tener esto paso a paso. Me
encanta. A ver, tenemos ya bastantes
preguntas. Me encanta de verdad tu
presentación. Dame, me acordé demasiado
de cada una de las experiencias en esos
haatons y sin ir tan lejos, por ejemplo,
cuando Ángela mencionaba, bueno,
deberían compartir esto directamente lo
que crearon y demás, me recuerda mucho a
una de las maneras en las que yo comencé
a trabajar en Stars. Yo trabajaba en
empresas tradicionales y de repente
comencé a aprender eh a hacer diferentes
proyectos de tecnología. Yo no era
desarrolladora, yo soy administradora de
empresas y comencé a aprender desarrollo
y comencé a publicar todo lo que hacía.
terminó contratándome directamente el
CEO de una startup en España que terminó
de una viendo mi perfil por LinkedIn.
Así que siempre este tipo de cosas
ayudan. Después de eso, cuando Bilbao
habló conmigo para comenzar a trabajar
en 30x, me decía, "Veo que has estado en
Hakaton, tú puedes hacerme un hacatón."
Y yo, "Obviamente, claro que sí, porque
fue gracias a justamente compartir toda
esta experiencia que teníamos en
Hakatons anteriores, que esto hoy es
realidad." y yo literal comencé en 30x
hace como 2 meses apenas y ya estamos
haciendo este super evento acá.
Entonces, bueno, ya sin contar va a
parar de contarles esa novela por allí.
Les contaré aquí cuáles son las
preguntas que tenemos.
Tenemos, "Hola, Ángela", lo dice Alejo y
el gatito. En el demo sugieres que la
sugieres solución al problema y el
diferencial frente a otros pit o solo
demo y al final, ¿qué alcanzaste a hacer
de más?
Uy, esa
lo primero que se me viene al
pensamiento, voy a ser muy honestjo, es
este meme de Michael Phelps nadando y
luego cuando hay otro nadando que lo
está mirando, pero Michael Phelps está
viendo la meta, enfócate en tu producto,
ese es el TLVR. Ah, entonces enfócate en
mostrar la solución o por qué tu
proyecto es único versus a otros pitch.
Ah, lo que sí haría, por ejemplo, es
buscar productos allí afuera, no sé si
tú estás tratando de crear el próximo
NKI. Ah, o el próximo Plati o el próximo
Rapi o el próximo 30X, cómo ellos
presentan y quizá que te sirva de
inspiración, pero muéstraste, enfócate
en ah qué hace tu producto único ah y
luego qué es lo que quieres hacer con
todo eso. Sería como mi recomendación.
Me encanta. Tenemos otra pregunta por
acá de ¿Cómo estás? Primero que nada y
si al final del si al final todos los
equipos presentan prototipos
funcionales, ¿qué hace que el jugador
recuerde uno en particular? y decida que
merece ganar. Eso está muy buena. Esta
pregunta
es una gran pregunta. Eh, para darles
contexto, yo empecé a eh ser jurada hace
unos dos o tres años. Eh, los primeros
el primer año fue muy fácil porque no
todos llegaban a presentar cosas como
tan concretas, tipo interfaces tan
limpias. Hoy es muy fácil tener ah una
una interfaz o un prototipo que
funcione. ¿Qué hace que un equipo sea
diferencial del otro? que tenga una
estructura la la presentación y que sepa
explicarme cuando yo pregunto cosas.
Entonces, yo trabajo en el área de
blockchain y siempre que alguien me
llega con la nueva Deffi aplicación que
va a reemplazar a todos los major
players, suelo preguntar muchísimos
diferenciales, solo preguntar y cómo
solucionaste este problema. La mayoría
de las personas con ella hoy me dicen,
no sé. Entonces, por ejemplo, en la
parte de Textac, yo les recomendaría un
montón que traten de incluir cómo
resolvieron el problema. Eh, y eso a mí
siempre dice, "Ah, esta persona sabe lo
que está haciendo, sabe eh lo planeó,
sabe cómo presentarlo y usualmente ah
tiene como más puntos de mi lado."
Pueden haber otros approaches o formas
de evaluarlo, pero esto es lo que a mí
más me emociona cuando alguien con
pasión presenta su proyecto, cuando lo
presenta con orden, pero además sabe lo
que está haciendo y cómo lo hizo.
Maravilloso. Ahora tenemos esta pregunta
de Juan. Hoy todos tienen nombres
normales. Me encanta porque ayer y
antier, no, ayer tenía unos nombres muy
raros que sí, muchas letras y ningún no
tenía sentido leer. Gracias por ponerse
sus nombres normales en en YouTube.
Mira, tenemos acá que tomar en cuenta si
queremos generar un efecto wow.
Ah, el hook eh del principio es algo que
a mí me me llama mucho la atención. Ah,
entonces de nuevo, ah, muchas personas,
lo puedo prometer, comienzan diciendo,
"Hola, me llamo Ángela y entonces yo
hago esto, eh, y nada, durante la hacat
y son como 30 segundos en que yo estoy
como, Dios mío, arranca." Eh, so yo
empezaría con una con un con un hook y
un problema claro y sobre todo con
datos. A mí el efecto wow es cuando
digo, "Ah, wow, me supieron mostrar y y
demostrar y argumentar cada cosa." Lo
otro sería una interfaz muy limpia. en
una interfaz tan generada por AI. Eh,
eso honestamente a mí me emociona mucho,
por eso le digo, "Prefiero que usen
templates a que en serio se note
demasiado." Ah, no les estoy diciendo,
"No la usen ojo. Yo uso en mi día a día.
Ah, y hoy justo lanzamos un feature que
yo construí y usamos AI. Ah, pero es muy
distinto usar la infraestructura. Ah,
toma todas las decisiones por mí. Eso
para mí, Juan, genera un efecto wow. Ah,
un buen producto. Ah, que esté
presentado con datos y que empiece con
un buen one hook. Ah, sí.
¿Dónde estás?
Bien, maravilloso. Aquí estoy. Ya, bien.
Acá me encanta esta esta respuesta acá
que gracias por tu consejo, que Dios te
bendiga, me encanta. Y bueno, ya creo
que por ahora no tenemos más preguntas.
De igual forma pueden hacer todas las
preguntas que tengan directamente en el
grupo de WhatsApp. Ahí tenemos grupo por
reto, grupo por mentores, grupo general.
Ahí pueden hacer todas las preguntas por
donde quieran hacerlas y directamente
todo el equipo de 30x y de Coluxsidio
que estamos trabajando en este evento,
vamos a ayudarlos a responder lo más
pronto posible. Entonces, Ángela, como
siempre, muchísimas gracias por estar
acá, por apoyarnos con esta gran charla.
Por favor, me envías las slides para
poder pasárselas y si tienen alguna
pregunta, ya saben, nos las pueden dejar
por el WhatsApp. Gracias a todos los que
se conectaron. Espero que esos piches
sean espectaculares y tengan ese efecto.
Wow. Tengan eso de de una en vez de
decir, "Hola, mi nombre es Sandra ta ta"
tá. De una entren diciendo, "Pum, estoy
solucionando esto." Bien, muchas gracias
Ángela, y gracias a todos por unirse.
Voy a finalizar por ahora la
transmisión. Hasta luego.